♪ ♪ ♪
- S'il y a une affaire qui est
juste, c'est bien la mort.
On passe tous par là
un jour ou l'autre.
Mais moi, ça me fait pas peur,
pas du tout.
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ Dis-moi qu'on est
deux ma belle ♪
♪ Et qu'il y a ta v
qui m'appelle ♪
♪ Et dis-moi qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire ♪
♪ On fait l'amour,
on fait la guerre ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
- Bossy is alone! s s s shoots,!
- Paul-André Comeau, à Londres.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Moi, il y a rien que je trouve
plus outrageant que de voir
sur une scène un plom
"toi et moi".
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il y a eu des momentsèèèèèès e
de les oublier, oui, c'est
certain, et de me rappeler
les belles choses.
♪ ♪ ♪
♪  J'avais 20 ans
pour les yeux d'une femme ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ Il faut toujours s'écouter,
mieux sans parler ♪
♪ Talk about it ♪lrlrlrlrlrlrlr♪
♪ Je m'enivre de ton corps ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ Comme j'ai
toujours envie d'aimer ♪
♪ J'ai toujours envie de toi ♪
- Moi, je suis plutôt
sprinteuse. Mais là, il fallait
que je sois marathonienne.fffff,
mais je savais dès le début
qu'il fallait que je tienne.
♪ ♪ ♪
- J'ai eu cette chance-là, oui,
j'ai travaillé avecutututututut.
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ J'ai quitté mon village ♪
♪ C'était pour venir en ville ♪♪
♪ ♪ ♪
- Rire, rire à g
à tous les jours de ta vie.
♪
- Montfort, fermez jamais!
♪ ♪ ♪
(commentat
(cris et applaudissements)
- (foule): Guy! Guy! Guy! Gu